very few people very very few people
translate to big dollars in viewership
Conor Rhonda this John Jones
not really it's amazing I have since
ever been forever either yeah brother
you got a have you got to put asses in
seats dude what do you let me tell you
something brother when it's all about
putting asses and see Hogan Knows yeah
dude you know Paul Orndorff never at
box-office King Kong Bundy never had box
let me tell you something when the
Hulkster filled that arena brother they
were always in there they're saying
there's marketing it's all code me tell
you some let me tell you something dude
in the WWE or the WWF like these club
when I was there and I slammed that big
dirty Andre the Giant right through the
mat WrestleMania 3 dude you want to put
an ass every 18 inches brother and if
what is his name Luke Rockhold rock rock
rock Brockman well let me tell you
something wrong yeah yeah rock brutal
he's some dude yeah if he's got those
good looks dude he's like Rick Rude
strutting his stuff and he might think
he's a good looking guy and he's got
he's got ford models dude he's got
Wilhemina models over here brother but
as soon as I dropped that big leg on him
and I snapped those skinny arms and legs
yeah brother yeah dude Luke is a real
fighter all right and he was my brother
from another mother dude CM punk dude
he's in UFC 203 well he is he's gonna
come he's gonna lay the smackdown
brother wow it's pretty general well
he's gonna come in that brown yeah what
do you think he's gonna do in the fight
you know CM what do you think is gonna
do let me tell you something brother I
didn't get a whole lot of chance to work
with CM now when I say work brother
there's work and then there's shoot dude
work means you know we like to keep it
kayfabe dude but here we'll tell you you
know wrestling is a it's a work dude but
it what it's not you know what well you
know no I don't walk you know
it's not real they said no no we know
that well yeah it's not really work I'll
say it's not real whoa hold on dude it's
work but no work no look you didn't say
do you bodyslam Kamala
that's real brother you see him go down
okay but maybe the so what you think
there's an pons worked out well yeah
they work it's called a work and then
they're shooting brother yeah guys that
are a shoot I mean you know when you
have guys coming in from you I mean
Brock Lesnar that's a shoot dude you
know I mean he's in the UFC he was an NC
double-a that's right yeah brother he's
held wrestler so Hulk Hogan dude from
playing bass yeah and then I was well no
hold on dude when Brock Lesnar comes in
he's he's in a shoot fight that's real
when he's in the dub in the UFC bro
yeah I mean oh that's right then when he
goes to WWE dude that's what work faces
Randy Orton it puts albo in his head
it's work dude yeah its own you know
work yeah yeah but they work the work
it's no awkward I asked you a question
dude
GM apart what's he gonna do oh he's
gonna hit that that GTS brother that go
to sleep he gets him up on his shoulders
and we're firemen stylin thinking he
hits that knee and then his opponent
brother he's gonna be out he's gonna go
to sleep bro well yeah I don't think he
think you'll get a three count well how
long is his opponent been wrestling in
the WWF sea fighter yeah he's at long
range II kid he's a big one he's a
purple belt in jujitsu and even bang
yeah but CM Punk was world champion the
WWE real fighting small it's a work dude
I don't want you to say that's what the
cause we're gonna go we're gonna have to
go hey Hulk great to see you all right I
can't wait to go to Madison Square gun
it's my town and I am going to be
cheering on Robbie another your Trump
Tower
it absolutely it's gonna be amazing all
the fighters stay at Trump Tower
everybody knows this and dirty crooked
Hillary will not
at UFC 2 you can see that though I
guarantee look when I take office yeah
and Robbie Lawler is the champion of the
was you caught us saying yeah
then he will be staying at Trump and
I'll tell you this we are going to cut
Isis off at the route Obama created ice
I don't think any here and my new
Secretary of Defense Robbie Lawler
Robbie law was gonna be your second head
of defend out Smith does he know this
yes that's amazing does he does he he
said I'm brilliant
he said Donald Trump is a brilliant man
okay Robbie doesn't seem like the best
choice to be secretary defense that's a
very intricate job you've got to know
geopolitics you've got to understand the
dynamics of American I call people up
for a favor and they kiss my ass okay
here's my ass you're very behind that
although I don't know your everybody
knows that thank you I don't believe in
unions of course you don't try
I pay vana $20 a month in alimony well a
lot well yeah but don't seem right
I'm there's me golly there's Mexicans in
the UC I love Mexicans they're stupid
and they're better than us and they're
losers and they're beating us and
they're winners and I love them you have
a lot of I don't know what you stand for
and I have no respect okay okay well
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]